[موسيقى]
انا هنا لريانه الاعمال عشان تعمل به عشان
نطلع من العقليه الموظف بعدين الموظف وبس
تمام نبدا النقطه الاولى
سؤال للتفكير
عشان البتاع ده فوق رؤوسه
ويكون خير
طيب اخواني
السودان
ايش
وتقعدي هنا
وعملوا بزنس عبر مصانع عمل
مطاعم عبر العقارات عبود
[موسيقى]
وطلعوا
واحد ويركب الطيارات وينزل لحد السودان
وينزل يعرف في منطقه اسمها الجزيره ويركب
من المطاعم قوي جزيره ويقعد مع المزارع في
الواقع ويقول ليه انت قا وهذا التمويل
وازرع القطن ويزرع القطن ويحلي ويصطر وان
احنا جعانين ما فينا
الحجر
يقرعوا احسن شمار الله خلقه في الدنيا
يتابعوه الناس
من وين يخشوا ويشيلوا منا شمال حقنا
على بعض عشان يصلحوه سابوه
اشتغل بالنفس
في السودان ده
كان مركزه معاه
وبدا سنين سنين من مشاكل لمشاكل لوضع
استثنائي مشاكل ربنا يخلي
دفاع والله يقول لك
فدي النقطه الاولى
ان الشباب
[موسيقى]
تركيا عشان
يقعد معاهم عشان
دولار عارفين انا لما كنت اشوف البيزنس
بتاعه وافتكروا شركه كبيره كده
واحده فيها غرفتين
اصابه الغرفه واحد
احنا
عايز اوري منك حتى
رمضان انا ما عندي لك حاجه مشغول
وهذا بس من المعاصر عندنا لكن عندنا تحس
يشتغلوا في البزنس بتاع طيب طيب
لكن محتاجين ناس طيب
اغلب الاسئله عاده في شباب ولم
[موسيقى]
ا
لكن ما قادر يعني ما قاعد
موجود كيف افتح اسواق وانا طيب
كيف احدد مشروعي
معايير معينه حاول انك تشتغل فيها استهدف
او صغرك الحكي اللي بتحبه حيث معي واحده
في غطاء استاذه كان بيتكلم
مشي ده يلا
ما شاء الله في مش حق
هذا كله
[موسيقى]
الصغيرونه دي شغاله
الكترونيا
هتمشي فيه
[تصفيق]
ما شاء الله عليهم ما شاء الله
حسي الناس المنظمين
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مره
كويس انت امشي لقدام
فيها غير فانت اشتغل في حته تتميز
اختار مجانا حتى واضح اهم نقطه
مجال واحد اكعب حاجه انك تتش
دد لي قبيله واحد بس
تمام في ناس بيكونوا قاعدين معانا شباب
الله
خمسه يوم بترجع راسك
اليوم
الثالث بيجيب جروب
[موسيقى]
العماله
تاني خلاص
[موسيقى]
التخصصيه اهم حاجه في النجاح ابغي مختصه
بالشيء في الالكترونيات اربع طب غالبا
بتشتغل لكنها قبل ماسكين حاجه مع
ينه ناس عندك شغالين تحياتي معينه اللي هي
بالتجاره الالكترونيه الناس قيوده خاص ما
يعملوا الطابعه لكنه التخصصيه يا اخواننا
اشتغلوا في المجال واحد
[موسيقى]
اموره في نهايه اي حاجه
في دوله واحده معروفه
بس بتعمل
واضح
ه كويسه الناس بيجينا عشان
تخصصون بيعمل
حق البنات ده كريم صح
كده
المندولين
مهندس هو صيدلي كيميائي شغف رقم واحد
اشتغل سوق الصح مت فبالتالي ذكاء ينتهي
طوال
الصيدليه فانت اشتغل اي بزنس
بس انا بصفي
[موسيقى]
وهو مخصص جروب عاجل
قالونا كويس
الجنود
على اي حاجه
المؤتمرات
صح طيب
مشروع يتوافق مع امكانيات متوافق مع
امكانيات كان في مسانع
طيب كيف الاول
مشروعك التمويل الذاتي هنا بروز بتمون
مشروعه التمويل بتاع العلاقات انت لما
يكون عندك مشروع
[موسيقى]
على نفس حوالينه
وابو علوم مش انجح الشركات انت لما يكون
عندك فكره وموضوع محدد كويس وفهمه تمام
ركز عليه فهمه تمام
حيويه ما في ناس عندها بروز معك
بس لكن
يجيب مشروع كيف طيب الدور
ركز في النقطه البنك حاليا انت زول مبتدئ
البيوت امثليها
ابتداء يعني انت
تمثيليه
كذا عايز
[موسيقى]
تطولها
كده كده
خلاص هتبقى ز
ودنا وهتبقى نوايا اكلتها وهذه الامور
تمام
[موسيقى]
يا جماعه
اهم حاجه انت مثلا حسي حاليا انتم يعني
[موسيقى]
لو كله جدع والله معلش ان شاء الله
انه
بتكلم عنها
انت السبب هي كم مليون دولار
تمويل الجماعي
[موسيقى]
التمويل الجماعي عشان تقدر تعمل لها كبير
تشتغل الموضوع
شركات المحترمه كبيره جدا كانت في السؤال
كانت
كيف عرفت
التسويق التكليف يلا بعد كده التسويقي لكن
تزور المعارض
للشركات مباشره
العلاقات البيزنس علاقه
[موسيقى]
المنزور والبحث في السوق اسمه حمدان السوق
مازال زول الليله الخدمات زعلك اليوم
الثاني عشان كذا بينك وبين شغل
تفتح اسواق عالم
يه ونفسك في العلاقات تقدر تفتح اسواق
وتقدر تستغرق عن طريق العلاقات وبالتالي
العلاقات وشراكه
العطاء والتلفاء وغيره اعطائه خارجيا انا
كده التصميم الرقمي معروفه في موقع
الالكتروني والتصريحه عبر الايميل على
التواصل الاجتماعي ومواقع
من الطرق بتاعه التصوير الالكتروني انا
التامه بالجوده
اهتم بالمصداقيه اهتم بالمصداقيه تخليك
زول امين خليك زوج دغري خليك زول واضح
تكون زوج امين
الناس بتشته
ما تعتمد على الناس وتتوكل اشتغل فيه
مصداقيه بامانه
مره اولى وثلاثه طوابعه والناس كلها
هتتكلم عنها
ده الرجل قاعد هنا ما تقعد حاليا احنا
قاعدين بندرب ونساعده الناس انت تدرب
وسائل غيرك والله
ربنا
بقيمه مضاعفه اياك تصدر بقيمه تضاف وفي
النهايه اكتب صنع
[تصفيق]